منك يا ينضم الينا دبلوماسيه السابق
فرودومير شوماكوب اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
شوماكوف ماذا بعد التصعيد الاخير العسكري
خاصه من جانب او هذا الحشد العسكري
الغربي في مواجهه موسكوما المنتظر
السلام عليكم
من المعادلات العسكريه المطلوبه ولكن على
العراق
ومن اجل هذه المساعده
بكره يعني هو كمان من محافظتها
[موسيقى]
الاوكراني اكيد عنده روسيا موجود انت رافع
عصبي لان روسيا تفضل لان تحارب وتقاتل وما
خاصه ضعيف ولكن من المنطقه يعني ان سيدنا
حموده
روسيا تطلب مفاوضات ولكن بوتين هو لا يطمع
السلام لان روسيا سوف تستخدم هذه الماهل
خلال مفاوضات يعني لي تعزيز قواتها لتخطيط
تعبير جزئيه تعبيه العمل بعدين روسيا سوف
تهاجموا على اوكرانيا مرض تانيا
بوتين هو انتقامي جدا
سوف نتخلص
منك
سوف تكون حرف في
اوكرانيا شهيه روسيه هي ضخمه قبل اوكراني
في سنه 2008 جورج سنه 2014
يقول بان همم انا موسكو او ان عفوا ان كيف
حتى الان لم تقدم اي اقتراحات جاده تاخذ
بعين الاعتبار المخاوف الامنيه الكثيره
لروسيا ما هي همم الصيغه التي ربما يمكن
اتفاق عليها في المرحله المقبله والمقصود
بالمخاوف الامنيه بالنسبه لموسكو
بصفه عامه
شروط اوكرانيه هي معروفه هذا تراجع روس من
اراضي اوكرانيه همم ضعفه تعويضات كمان
يعني مفاوضات مع روسي على شروط الروسيه
هذا امر غير مقبوله ان الروس تطلب منه
اوكرانيا يعتراف الاراضي المختلفه بانه
روسيه وان نعظه سلاح همم
كما قال لافراف
هلا شيء مضحك اي اي اييي ضمانات اوروبا
نعم شكرا جزيلا لاقدم له بس السابقه